you want
evidence so if You Came Upon a fireworks
display if you studied the direction and
speed of all of those bits and pieces of
that explosion even if you weren't there
at the beginning of it you can say what
happens if I turn the clock back well I
see which way it's going now let me go
backwards along that path what I will
find is that all the pieces will rejoin
themselves at some point in the past we
did a calculation very similar to this
for the entire universe we look at all
the galaxies of the universe and they're
expanding away from one another that
means they were closer yesterday last
year and 10 years ago a million years
ago a billion years ago let's keep
turning the clock back and when you do
that the entire universe was in the same
place at the same time we call that the
big bang no we did not observe it but
all evidence points to
it